كشفت شركة Run عما تسميه أول
خطوة صاروخية محلية الصنع تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت من المرجح أن تزيد من التوترات مع
الغرب إذا كان هذا صحيحًا وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية، فإن الصاروخ الموجه بدقة والذي
يسمى Fata يمكنه استهداف الأنظمة المضادة للصواريخ
لاختراق الدفاعات الجوية الأكثر تقدمًا
بما في ذلك القبة الحديدية الإسرائيلية.
تقول إيران إنه يستطيع السفر بسرعة 1400 كيلومتر
في الساعة تقريبًا لمسافة 1400
كيلومتر تقريبًا (900 ميل تقريبًا) للجري، ويصفها بأنها قفزة
أجيال في التكنولوجيا.
ويقول محللون غربيون إن موتر إيران الذي
تعرفه مبالغ فيه قتل الزنبق
قليلاً عن قدراته الصاروخية
الجميلة بوسي هي  نائب
الرئيس التنفيذي لمعهد كوينسي لفن
الحكم المسؤول، وهو أيضًا مؤلف كتاب
فقدان عدو، وقد مر وقت طويل، ومن
الجيد أن نراكم مرحبًا بكم مرة أخرى في
العرض،
شكرًا لكم على استضافتي، لذلك
تدعي إيران أن هذا الصاروخ الجديد الذي تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت
أعتقد أنه يمكن ذلك  تسافر بسرعة 15 ماخ، أي 15 ضعف
سرعة الصوت التي حذروا منها في
الماضي، ويمكنها الوصول إلى إسرائيل في 400 ثانية،
لذا إليك المزيد الآن من
رئيس
القوة الجوية الفضائية بالحرس الثوري، استمع إلى هذا
على مسافة 1400 كيلومتر نحن  يمكن أن
نضرب بدقة أي هدف نريده ولا يمكن لأي
نظام مضاد للصواريخ أن يتعامل معه،
هذا هو ما بعد الصين وروسيا
وكوريا الشمالية التي تدعي جميعها أنها طورت
صواريخ تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت أه مما يعني أن
إدراج إيران في تلك القائمة أعتقد أنها
كانت مسألة وقت فقط باستثناء  وهنا
لتوضيح أن لدى طهران نوعًا ما من
السمعة الطيبة في تضخيم
إنجازات برنامجها الصاروخي،
فهل يمكن أن تندرج هذه الادعاءات ضمن هذه
الفئة
بالتأكيد، وربما
ستفاجئ الكثير من العالم
إذا تبين أنها تمتلك هذا.
القدرة في هذه اللحظة ما نعرفه
في نفس الوقت هو أنه حتى لو
لم يمتلكوها الآن فقد
حققوا الكثير من
الاختراقات التكنولوجية التي لم تكن متوقعة،
فهم يمتلكون أكبر ترسانة من
الصواريخ في الشرق الأوسط واحدة من
أكبر على الأقل ودقة
صواريخهم أه في مرحلة
لم نتوقعها كذلك حتى لو كان
هذا الشيء المحدد قد يكون رئيسًا فهذا
لا يعني أنه بعد عام من الآن إلى
سنوات من الآن لن يفعلوا ذلك  لديك هذه
التكنولوجيا وقد تحدث الرئيس الإيراني
عن حقيقة أنك تعلم أن
هذا الصاروخ الذي تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت تم تطويره في
الداخل من خلال المعرفة والتكنولوجيا الإيرانية المحلية،
وإليك
المزيد من
هذه المعرفة بصنع الصواريخ والعلوم
والدفاع بالإضافة إلى الصواريخ
والعسكرية  لقد كانت الصناعات محلية
الصنع في بلدنا، وهي ليست
تكنولوجيا مستوردة، لذا لا يمكن للتهديدات
إزالة هذه المعرفة المتقدمة،
ويبدو من الصعب على الصناعة تصديق أن
طهران لم تحصل على مساعدة من أصدقائها المقربين في
موسكو، وتذكر أن الصواريخ الروسية التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت لم
تعمل بشكل جيد.  في
أوكرانيا حتى هذه اللحظة، لا تزال النقطة
هنا هي أن هذا الصاروخ، سواء تم
تصنيعه أو يجري بناؤه، يحدث
على الرغم من النظام الصارم
حقًا للعقوبات الاقتصادية الدولية وغيرها من العقوبات، صحيح
بالتأكيد والشيء هو أنه ربما يكون من
المبالغة الكبيرة أن هذا
كل شيء  التكنولوجيا المحلية بمعنى أنهم
اخترعواها ولكن
بمعنى أنهم ينتجونها
في الداخل بمعنى أنها أه بعيدة عن
متناول مختلف أشكال العقوبات
وهذا ربما يكون صحيحا لأن الإيرانيين
تطوروا في ظل العقوبات في بعض
الجوانب نتيجة للعقوبات الكثير
من هذه التقنيات والصناعات أه
كلها داخليا من أجل التأكد من
أن لديهم هذه المعرفة أه دون أن
يتعرضوا لمخاطر
العقوبات التي تعطلها وتقول
وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية إنها على علم
يدعي متحدث رسمي يشير أيضًا إلى
الجهود المستمرة لمحاولة منع إيران
من تطوير هذه التكنولوجيا. استمع
إلى هذا،
نحن نواصل استخدام مجموعة متنوعة من
أدوات الانتشار غير المؤيدة بما في ذلك العقوبات
لمواجهة التقدم الإضافي في
برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية الإيراني
وقدرته على نشر الصواريخ.
والتكنولوجيا ذات الصلة للآخرين، أود أن أقول
إنه على الرغم من القيود المفروضة على
أنشطة إيران المتعلقة بالصواريخ بموجب
قرار مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة رقم 2231،
تواصل إيران البحث عن مجموعة من
تقنيات الصواريخ من الموردين الأجانب
وإجراء اختبارات الصواريخ الباليستية
في تحدٍ للقرار الذي
تقوم به.  أكثر بكثير من السعي لتحقيق ذلك،
فأنت تعرف أصوات
الأشياء والعقوبات بمعزل عن غيرها،
وتعلم أنها ربما تتباطأ
قليلاً هنا ببرامجها الصاروخية
والنووية، لكنها لا
تغلق هذه البرامج تمامًا،
لذلك في هذا الوقت  أشير إلى ما سيفعله،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء،
لم تنجح العقوبات والعزلة الصحيحة تمامًا،
وهذا واضح تمامًا لو كانت
ستنجح، لما كنا في
الوضع الحالي،
الولايات المتحدة الوحيدة التي نجحت في تغيير
سياسة الأمن القومي الأساسية في إيفانيا
لقد مرت الدبلوماسية والمفاوضات
التي جرت حول خطة العمل
الشاملة المشتركة، وهذا هو المثال الوحيد الذي
تمتلكه الولايات المتحدة على قدرتها على تغيير
العقوبات السياسية المفروضة على إيران، وكل هذه
التدابير المختلفة تؤدي في بعض الأحيان إلى إبطاء
تقدمها ولكنها تميل في الوقت نفسه
إلى تكثيفها.  تصميمهم على الحصول على
هذه التكنولوجيا، فما الذي ننظر
إليه هنا ربما يكون نوعًا من إحياء
الاتفاقية النووية روحًا إذا
أردت، والتي تم تعليقها لفترة
طويلة جدًا لمحاولة إبطاء هذه البرامج غير المشروعة،
لذا فهو برنامج صاروخي و
ربما لا يكون برنامجهم النووي تلك النسخة المحددة
من الاتفاق النووي الذي تم التوصل إليه في عام 2015، لكن خطة العمل الشاملة المشتركة
ليست أيضًا الطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكن من خلالها للدبلوماسية أه تحقيق اتفاق، لا يزال من
الممكن أن تكون هناك مفاوضات من
شأنها أن تعالج بعض هذه القضايا
وما زال من الممكن أن يكون لها
أعتقد أنه من المهم أن
ندرك في نفس الوقت أن السعوديين
على سبيل المثال، الذين أنفقوا 75 مليار
دولار على الأسلحة التي فازوا بها على السعوديين في العام الماضي
يفوقون الإيرانيين
بعامل  11.
يتفوق الإسرائيليون على الإيرانيين بعامل
ثلاثة ونصف. خلاصة القول هي أن
هناك الكثير من الأسلحة والكثير من
المشتريات المسلحة في المنطقة إذا أردنا
تقليلها، فنحن بحاجة إلى اتباع
نهج شامل تجاهها لا أحد  سوف
تقوم البلاد
بنقطة جيدة من جانب واحد للانتهاء من التاجر، شكرًا
جزيلاً لكونك معنا، نحن نقدر ذلك،
شكرًا لاستضافتي